。
接着往下说。
第十二趴39分钟。
这个。
南一和男二啊red安迪和red两个人下棋，这个安迪提出来他要自己刻旗子啊，这个呢也是个小伏笔啊，小伏笔呃，很后面才兑现的。但更重要的是，他们这里关于人有罪还是无罪，再次进行讨论。
再次进行讨论，readd在这里承认自己有罪。我们说这是一个非常重要的伏笔。为什么最后得到真正得到自由的只有安迪和red呢？这里埋下了伏底伏笔red是真的忏悔自己的罪行啊，真的忏悔自己的罪行，这是第十2趴啊。
非常短的一场戏，但是值得单独作为一个节拍。同学们有时候一个节拍就一场戏一分钟。有的时候一个节拍七八场戏十来分钟，这都很正常啊。
因为他节拍不是按照时间，不是按照目分的。
同学们啊，你们自己写的那个节拍，跟老师写的只要大差不差就可以，明白吗？不用非常的精准，但是尽量要跟老师写的接近。因为老师写的给你们拉的节拍是按照创作的思维，就我们去共情当时这个编剧是咋写的，或者这个导演是怎么安排这些戏的。
共情他们啊，来下一排。
第十三趴第十三拍。
第40分钟啊，距离上一场戏只有一分钟啊，第十3拍第40分钟，他晚上在雕刻棋子的时候，发现墙皮很松，这里也单独做一拍，只有几秒钟的一戏，但是要单独做一拍，因为后面有呼应啊，因为后面都用得上，所以这一场戏也是单独一场有用的戏，他发现墙皮很松。
因为在这里我们其实不知道他要越狱，但是墙壁很松，又给了我们一个强烈暗示。
十四拍41分钟。
看电影。
我们说又只过了一分钟。
为什么又单独说他是一拍呢？因为又是一次越狱暗示看电影安y向red索要女明星的海报啊，美女海报暗示这里计划已经开始了，明白吗？14场其实如果我们全部来复盘的话，从这一场戏开始，他已经开始在挖地道了。
啊，因为我们需要复盘才知道啊，所以这里先打个点。
第十五拍42分钟。
安迪再次被姐妹团攻击，也就是姐妹团啊。
在这里要完成他的历史使命了。
安迪再次被姐妹团攻击。
被打的很惨啊被打的很惨，但是没有失节。
或者是说这次没有时节，因为影片并没有明确讲述他之前有没有被搞过啊，没有没有明确讲述之前有没有被搞过，只是讲他每次都反抗。
然后这次它并没有湿结，非常强硬啊非常强硬。
你也可以理解为他的一个成长。
然后。
这个姐妹团被狱警打成了残废，也就是说他刚才不是帮助过那个狱警吗？这里狱警回馈他，把姐妹团打成了残废，这是好几场戏啊，这是好几场戏，但是是同一个节拍。第16拍46分钟，伙伴们一起找石头送给安迪，甚至还送给他免费的美女海报啊。
我们说这一拍也是很有用的。
展现了安迪已经获得了大家的认可。
所以说一小场戏我们单独把它拎出来。
然后第十七排实际是第17拍，实际是第48分钟点狱长查房，这场戏也是一场单独的节拍，为什么呢？因为它看似是一场小小的危机。我们在看戏的时候啊会觉得是一场小危机。
但是呢其实这场小危机有个非常重要的作用。
就是通过典狱长严格的查房来展现安迪，其实没有搞什么小动作啊，来展现安迪，又是一次这个这个拿捏我们观众啊，又是一次挑逗我们观众，让我们观众认为他其实没有搞什么小动作，对吧？
然后从典狱长的角度呢，实际是在试探安迪，因为他想要开始用安迪给他干活了啊，他想要开始试探安迪可不可靠了。然后在这里呢还做了一个很重要的伏笔。第1七拍这里还有一个很重要的伏笔，就是圣经啊，圣经伏笔救赎之道就在其中，这是一个很重要的伏笔啊。
呃，我们待会儿全部都拉完了之后，我们来讲一下圣经这个伏笔啊，十八拍是51分钟51分钟啊。我们说安y。
开始。
给典狱长打工了啊，去到图书馆啊，去到图书馆。
就去图书馆打工了，就开始成为一个文职人员了。
在这里啊，当然还那个另外一个比喻又兑现，又出现了一下，就是老布和那只鸟啊，老布和乌鸦这个比喻又出现了一遍。1八拍这场戏很重要的是。
他接到了第一单咨询订单啊，而且两个人非常煞有介事的坐下谈，而且还摘一下帽子，非常这里展现什么呢？展现安迪的知识得到了尊重啊。记住第十八拍非常重要，安迪第一次得到了尊重。
十九拍55分钟。
安迪的世迹啊在监狱广为传颂。
同时呢他也开始申请经费改善图书馆。当然了，狱警告诉他，这件事情是没什 impossiblepos啊，不可能做到的事情，但是他不管啊，他不管他呢就是要申请经费改善图书馆。同时呢也。
开始帮所有的预警以及典狱长报税啊，典狱长报税这个成为。
成为了一名。
监狱会计师啊，第二十拍二十拍。
也就是第57分钟老布发疯了啊，这一场戏单独单独说写一下，因为是老布的结局啊，老布发疯了啊，虽然是好多场戏，但是讲的是老布的结局。
老布是一种人啊，大家记住老布是一种人。老布发疯了啊，老布因为即将要出狱，所以发疯了，他没有办法面对外面的世界，也离不开这个监狱啊。呃，在临走之前，他放飞了他的小鸟啊，让他的小鸟获取去自由，然后他自己走出了监狱，面对外面未知的世界啊，我们最终呢承受不住自杀了啊。当然这一切。
这一切从监狱的视角我们是怎么知道的呢？是因为老布写信回来告诉大家的啊，这场戏挺长的，有8分钟啊，有8分钟。但是讲的是老布的结局。我们说老布作为一个这么不重要的角色，只出现了这么两三次。
在这里花了8分钟讲他的死亡，为什么嘞？是因为他是监狱有罪之人，其中的一种典型代表，他的结局是一种典型结局，明白吗？这个待会儿你看通过一部哎。
同学们刚刚刚讲到第二0拍。
有没有？
慢慢的感觉这个片子的类型啊、四目啊，一句话故事啊全都要全都要呼之欲出啦。
第2十1趴。
也就是第65分钟65分钟。
换个词儿说叫一个点啦。同学们，这部电影一个点啦。
该那啥了啊。
21趴65分钟。
地获得了拨款，获得了捐赠，6年的坚持，获得了回报。而且呢还获得了音乐唱片，播放了莫扎特，品尝到了最自由的味道。美好的音乐这个音乐呀。
让人铭记，因为他说问别人问他，你放音乐值得吗？他说值得，因为音乐是就是希望，音乐是关不住的，你的肉体可以被关注。
对吧你的嘴巴可以被关注，胃可以被关注，音乐是关不住的，它是字眼。
我们说在这里他品尝到了自由。
但也因此被关了两周的禁闭啊，我们说你看。
你可以理解是这样，第21趴也就第65分钟，也就是这个电影的。
一个钟头这个位置啊一个点中间这个位置。
安迪在监狱混到了巅峰了。
就安迪作为一个在监狱里混的人，在肖申克这个监狱里混的人，他现在是人生巅峰。
可以他可以跟。
狱警平起平坐，他可以自由的走动，他甚至都敢放音乐啊，他还有钱，他还那个呢是图书馆馆长，他还是会计师混到巅峰了。
65。
65分钟啊，混到巅峰了来。
下面进入第22趴啊，也就是第73分钟。
re。
申请假释，再次被拒，希望再次破灭。我们记得啊开场就有red申请假释这么一场戏，这里在故事终点刚刚过完，red再一次申请假释，然后呢再次被拒。这时候的red已经入狱30年整安y是入狱十年整。
同学们。
安迪一共在监狱蹲了多少年？
在监狱一共蹲了20年。
同学们，安迪在监狱一共蹲了20年。
在故事终点的时候是十年啊，这里red入狱30年，安迪入狱1年啊。
在这里呢，安迪赠送给red一个口琴，一个代表希望的口琴。但是red不肯。
演奏。
肯演奏，甚至到了晚上夜深人静，只有他一个人的时候，他尝试把口把这个口琴含在嘴里。
依然不敢。
然后呢，red也回赠了安迪玛丽莲梦露啊，代表一个新的时代的美女啊，玛丽莲梦露。
然后两个人呢在晚上都陷入了思考啊，陷入了迷失，陷入了思考啊。
第23趴76分钟。
安迪再次获得拨款。
扩建图书馆。与此同时，典狱长也在此期间利用安底搞的这个这个呃所谓的这个狱警叫囚犯再造运动。因为他囚犯在教育嘛，他在一直在这个监狱里面搞囚犯在教育。典狱长也利用他搞的这个囚犯再教育。
开始发了大财啊，利用这些监狱的免费劳动力发了大财。
然后呢，安y就一直在帮他洗钱啊，一直在帮他洗钱。
嗯，这在这里也交代了那些账本呀、保险柜呀这些东西。
也用安迪和red的一场对话交代了洗钱的细节啊，也成为了伏笔啊。就是安y向red介绍他是怎么洗钱的。red因为完全外行嘛，完全听不懂，所以把这里用这场戏。
呃，把洗钱过程交代一下，同时也是一个很重要的伏笔。然后来到24场。
24趴啊，就是第84分钟啊，这里你看没趴分钟数就很多了啊，又来新人了啊，又来了一个新人。这个新人呢汤米这个汤米呢显然是一个舍牛啊。
84分钟。
新人汤米来到。
来到了。
监狱快速融入融入集体。与此同时呢，与之对比的安迪已经成为了监狱的老油条。为什么说他为什么说他成为了监狱的老油条呢？因为他对这个t米说的话。
就像red当年对他说的话一样啊，就像当他呃就是当年red对新人的他20年前对他说的话一样，t米拜了安迪为师啊，安迪决定帮助汤米。
安迪决定帮助汤米拿到一个中学文凭。
为了重新做人。
两人成为了师徒啊然后呢这个汤米啊进步神速，那这个汤米跟着安迪学了一年，一年之后已经准备好了参加考试啊就是。
两人有这么一年的一个师徒关系，这么这个一年用了6分钟来交代啊，但是其实是一拍啊，一个节拍，二4场啊是一个节拍。
第25拍。
第25拍来到90分钟。
这个汤米呀。
忽然想到了一个重要的线索。
这个重要的线索可以证明安迪是被冤枉。
我们说这场戏非常重要。
安迪发现了一个。
新的希望，也就是说，安迪。
发现了一个可以获得自由的希望。
但是典狱长。
并不打算帮他还把他关了一个月禁币。这里也强调了一下，说从来没有人被关过一个月禁币这么长。
记住这里有个时间点啊，这里打了一个时间点，这是安迪入狱的第。
19年下一拍第26拍。
第二十六拍。
也就是第94分钟，汤米。
获得了。
高中文凭。
主角安y的徒弟，我们的小汤米获得了中学文凭。
但是。
却被典狱长。
杀人灭口。
那我们的安迪能怎么办呢？
我们的安底没有任何办法。
只能被迫继续替典狱长做坏事。
整个故事来到了。
灵魂黑夜。
下一排第。
27拍。
2十7盘。
在故事的第100分钟。
安迪出来了安迪出来。
安利关禁闭出来之后，忏悔自己。
也宣告自己赎罪结束。
他认为他所犯的错误。
在这20年里已经全部。
还给了。
上利，而且安迪向red发出了出狱以后的邀请，告诉你，你到时候来找我。
然后但是这个red很悲观，他听不懂安迪在说什么，他以为安迪疯了。
但是安迪非常坚持告诉他，你到时候到哪棵树下找哪颗石头。
来找我，然后第二8拍。
107分钟第28拍的107分钟，大家都开始担心这个安迪感觉他是不是疯了，要自杀了。
甚至发现安弟还要了根绳子，对吧？发现安弟还要了根绳子，以为他肯定要自杀了。
我们说在大高潮戏来临之前，这个创作者再次虚晃一枪是吧？再次虚晃一枪，让我们以为安迪要自杀。然后第29拍。
来到第108分钟啊来到第108分钟，安迪拿走了啊，拿走了，就来到了故事的大高潮汐啊，大高潮系，安迪拿走了典狱长的。
账本呀、皮鞋呀在一个雨夜啊，趁着雨夜打雷，逃出了肖申克。
然后这一段叙述。
用了一个倒叙，用了一个倒叙，就是先查查寝，发现它没了，然后再去回忆越狱过程。
然后。
甚至也回忆了安迪这19年，从第一次开始挖通道，一直到现在，其实他一直在努力，一直在留有退路。我们说第108分钟是整个故事的大高潮戏，我们来看一下啊，我们来看一下。
个大学。
卖怎么事？
2245,,好 show.
Don't make me come down there, I'll you show for you.
Let me behind got把 me来 you me.
Oh myO的 god.
山。
just wasn't here. don't say that to me. don say that to me again, but sorry he wasn't I can see that he, they got blind, you say I I he sir about you blind you see the friends there. I should do see right there. do friend.
你不是 like job3 reason求别人的 morning人。
I want him found now tomorrow now after breakfast now yes.
不了。
I you all the time. You biggest Steve you are.
立马是在山上等等，我想。
老二这明头。
I wind then window on the wall Maybe she knows. What are there funny bridge like not.
She different。
该 what this is.
别，去来。
名场面啊明场面。
第一次看这场戏，那必须鸡皮疙瘩。
1966 and a Du frame escaped from Shahen prison.
All they found the animals a mud set of prison clothes, a bar of soap, and oldry, family worn down to the oven.
Thinking it would take a man 600 years to come through the wall with it. Oh landed less.
回到他当时第一次发现墙皮松啊，回到他当时19年前第一次发现。
Oh, and love Ge. I imagine appeal to this metic nature.
it是 mountain doing there.
第二个觉得3里该始人太。
诶，嘴了没事。
I said in prison a man do knows anything to deep mind occupied.
Turns out and his favorite I was building his wall I didnt emphasize yard, I hadn' at the time. I guess at the time it was killed and he decided he be adjust about vomit.
起。
And it did like it was sold, but those shoes to a high mirror shine.
didn't notice I mean, seriously, how often do you really look at man shows.
And crawl to freedom through 500 yards of shitsnel foul as I can't even imagine.
500 yards that' the length of five football fields, just shy half a mile.
来接着说啊。
我们说同学说哎呀，老师这场戏啊，其实挺这个镜头挺俗的呀，下大雨，然后张开双手大大雨冲刷我吧。说这种戏我们在偶像剧里经常见到说这个场会不会有点俗啊，人家是祖宗。
在学他嘛，明白吗？
就后面的戏都在学他呀，明白这个道理吧？所以说这场戏在当年啊那还是很震撼的啊，当年还是很震撼的啊。
呃，另外呃讲一个细节啊，同学们这场这场戏就是第29趴啊，第29趴从108分钟开始的全剧的。
大高潮系啊大高潮系。
说几个细节吧啊，我们说安迪为什么会带上棋盘啊？同学。
他刻了一堆一堆石头棋子儿，同学们看到没有？
他刻了一堆石头棋子儿。
那些石头棋子儿按理说挺沉的，同学们他还带，不是他不光带了石头棋子儿，他还带了。
还带了一本圣经。
带着的累赘挺多的。按理说如果是我的话，就带着那个带着那个典狱长的账本实际就行了，你知道吧？带着典狱长的账本还不行啊，是吧？为什么要带这么多？
很沉的东西啊，零碎的东西。
这个确实值得一说啊，为什么呢？因为通篇安底都在追求希望。
和自由。
我们说通篇安地在整个故事中，在整个的20年当中，他都在追求希望和自由。
我们随便回忆一下，他追求了几几次希望和自由啊。比如说。
他为什么要搞雕刻？最开始的时候为什么为什么搞搞雕刻？最开始的搞雕刻不是为了越狱。他第一次要锤子的时候，不是为了越狱。
是认他认为一个有尊严的人应该有自己的爱好。
一个有尊严的一个自由的人，应该有自己的爱好，爱好是别人抹杀不了的。就像他后来为什么鼓励red去吹口琴。
他觉得一个人的爱好是一个人不同于区别于其二人的地方。
是我们的自由。后来他为什么去听音乐是吧？也追求自由。
他为什么要？
在工作之后获得一瓶啤酒，他为什么要帮助那个很坏的。
呃，那个那个警卫，然后呢去换取别人付给他的报酬，别人付给他啤酒作为报酬是吧？自由。所以说他通篇啊一直在追求自由和希望。
那他最后这一个大招追求最大的这个自由和希望的时候，他是不能撇下他之前的成果的啊，他不能撇下他的信仰。因为下棋音乐都是他的信仰，包括圣经啊，都是他的信仰，甚至。
换把自己残破的圣经留给了留给了典狱长，把典狱长那本那本完整的圣经给拿走了。所以说这些都是代表希望啊，代表他对是自由的向往，所以他都得带走啊，都得带。
我们先把节拍讲完先把节拍讲完，笔记接着记啊，笔记接着记。
第三十拍。
第30拍从第109分钟开始。
也就是这个故事的结局。
第30拍第109拍第109分钟开始来到故事的结局。安迪呢西装革履的来到银行，非常潇洒的取走了存款，也举报了典狱长。然后呢，接到举报典狱那个狱警伏法，典狱长自杀。
然后red通过明信片得知安迪已经去到了墨西哥。
然后安y的故事成为了监狱的传说，成为了大家的偶像。我们说这是这个故事的结局。从第109分钟开始，这个结局持续了17分钟。
这个结局持续了17分钟。
安迪到银行去取走钱，举报典狱长典狱长伏法。
典狱长自杀，然后明信片得知安迪已经去到墨西哥成为监狱的传说和偶像。我们说这一这一整坨戏是一个节拍，因为它是剪在一块儿的，它是混捡在一块儿的。
我们说这里讲的就是安迪的结局。
他刚才大高潮戏是逃出监狱，但是结局需要安放一下观众的情绪。
这是第3十盘。按理说。
按理说。
一部电影，一部以安迪为主角的电影到这里就结束了，30拍就结束了。
但是。
加了。
加了一拍加了一拍啊，这里是安y的结局啊，有同学说他拆了好几个拍，没问题，你可以拆开。因为有十几分钟呢，你可以拆，没问题。我给你拆的是编剧的思路。
你有可能拆的是导演思维啊，你有可能拆的是导演思维，没有问题。
我给你拆的是编剧思维，这场戏就是结局，这一坨戏就是结局，都是为观众安放情绪的这一坨戏全都是完成了一个任务。
就是。
安迪的结局。
然后这个故事他还有第31盘。
还有red的结局。
第31拍。
是从126分钟开始，我们说也很长这个。
作者用了一大段篇幅去讲readd的结局。因为red作为这个故事的讲述者，作为这个旁白的主人啊，作为旁白的主人，这个电影的创作者或者电影的导演认为他配得上有自己的结局，配得上有自己的人物弧线，配得上也有属于自己的。
肖申克的救赎，所以来到第31排。
第126分钟re。
再次申请保释。
我们说啊re再次申请保释，我们看一看re三次申请保释都在什么位置，同学们别说年份。
在故事的第一场。
在故事的正中间。
故事的最后一场牛不牛？
故事的第一场，故事的正中间。
故事的最后一场，red作为一个不是主角的人。
对吧其实是这个故事的视角人物讲述者。
竟然拥有三场这么牛逼的戏，竟竟然拥有三个这么好的位置，用它打脸了，你看看厉不厉害？
在这里呢，red再次申请保石，再次呼应。
出场戏，我们说一头一尾要一样啊，戏谑的态度啊。
呃，获得了批准，用信谑的态度获得了批准啊。
呃，也是一场名场面，他呢一样。
呃，走了一个全过程，也来到老布打工的超市，也一样不能适应社会。但是不同的是什么呢？他和安迪有约定，他跟老布最大的区别就是他有希望，他有安迪对他的承诺，他有安迪和他的约定，他有安迪送他的口琴。
然后他找到了这个信物。
找到了这个信物，然后呢。
来到墨西哥的小岛，跟安迪团聚了。
我们说这场戏长达10分钟，red竟然拥有自己长达10分钟的一个情绪安放男配角儿，你可以理解为男2号。
男二号也行，男配角也行，但他绝对够不上双男主啊，绝对够不上双男主。
男配角也好，呃，关于他是不是双赞注，待会儿我们可以辩论一下子。
男配角啊拥有一个自己属于自己的长达10分钟的情绪安放。
而且这里再次通过它那么有磁性的旁白啊。
再次狠狠的点题，又讲了好几个京剧，觉得人啊。
人生你可以忙着死，也可以忙着活。
一定要充满希望，充满希望是吧？狠狠的点题啊，狠狠的点题。
我们说这就是这故事啊。
31个节拍从编剧角度啊从编剧角度。当然同学们跟我有个正-1的出入啊，正-1的出入都没有问题啊。同学们，如果你拉着节拍跟老师拉的节拍有个正-十的出入都没有问题啊，都没有任何问题，无非就是颗粒度的问题啊，老师只是告诉大家。
编剧的颗粒度应该在这个程度。因为我们是按照你脑子里面想1一场一坨一坨细的时候是这么想的啊，是这么想的。
我们先来探讨几个问题啊探讨先节拍拉完了，我们先来探讨几个问题，待会儿再聊一句话故事，待会儿再聊故事类型，待会儿再聊谁是主角，待会儿再聊。
不。